[Music]
lily has risked her life working on the
front lines in one of the most dangerous
settings for covet 19
deaths in the country long-term care
homes
she's been working as a personal support
worker in toronto providing care for the
most vulnerable
since 2014 when she came here on a
temporary work permit
i like my job i actually want to stay in
this field
make sure that i can give my clients the
best of me
during the pandemic we've been calling
people like lily heroes
despite caring for people on the front
lines of this health crisis
lily herself doesn't have access to the
same health care as canadians
she's undocumented we're not using her
real name
as she fears she could be deported it's
something that plays on your mind
every single day that you could be found
out that you know
that you could lose everything you're
trying to get here
because she works in long-term care she
should have been one of the first people
to receive the vaccine
in january her employer sent an email
asking staff for their provincial health
card in order to get it
something she does not have we are on
the front lines every day like everybody
else
and still we are being bored still if
you would have told your employer that
you didn't have an ohip card
what do you think would have happened if
they find out you do not have
this card you can be fired because and
then what will be your position you have
no money
you have to live here you have to have a
place to live you can't pay bills
employers shouldn't have control over
whether workers have access to the
vaccine or not
these are already relationships where
employers have
far too much control that's faye faraday
she's a labor and human rights lawyer
who has worked with migrant and
undocumented workers
for more than 30 years they're our
neighbors there are friends there are
co-workers
they need access to the vaccine despite
assurances from federal and provincial
governments that the vaccine will be
available to everyone
regardless of status the reality on the
ground is quite different
there's fear and confusion advocates say
the way provinces are approaching
vaccination
excludes and marginalizes migrant
workers and undocumented people
despite being some of the most at risk
they have to make up their minds
if they want to pretend that we're not
here or if they want to include
us in in this in this thing because it's
not discriminative against people like
us it goes after
everyone more than 1.6 million people
in canada are migrants refugees or
undocumented
that's one in every 23 people
they come here through canada's various
temporary foreign worker programs
study permits or without documentation
at all
they work in various frontline
industries such as healthcare
delivery farming construction and in
warehouses
this isn't something that's in the
cracks and the margins in the shadows
and there are significant sectors in our
economy that would grind to a halt and
businesses that would shut down
without undocumented labor while
essential workers have received thanks
and
praise for those with temporary status
or no status at all
the last year has been devastating like
many canadians
migrants and undocumented people have
lost their jobs during this crisis
but unlike most canadians they cannot
access emergency financial aid
they also don't have access to health
care
dr paul callford has been caring for
migrant and undocumented people for more
than two decades
he started this volunteer clinic in
scarborough with some colleagues
after witnessing an undocumented
teenager almost die after being denied
care
we hoped we'd be out of business in one
year after we told everybody what we
found in 1999 and we're still here 23
years later and we're still seeing the
same thing
when the coronavirus spread to canada
paul knew it would be devastating to the
population he treats
in march 2020 paul says six people with
symptoms of covid19
were all turned away from hospital and
told they would have to pay for care
outraged by this he started organizing
with other advocacy groups to call on
the federal and ontario governments to
expand
coverage if you don't treat everyone
in your community and it's a pandemic
you treat
no one everyone is at risk eventually
ontario and a few other provinces
temporarily expanded health coverage to
uninsured people
but the reality is it's not working that
well
many hospitals did not implement it for
the longest time
and now as provinces begin rolling out
vaccines
paul and other advocates are sounding
the alarm bells again
the migrant rights network and 270
organizations
are calling on federal and provincial
governments to ensure the people have
safe
and dignified access to the vaccine
regardless of immigration status
global news reached out to the
ministries of health in ontario british
columbia and quebec
provinces that have large numbers of
migrants and undocumented people
to see what information someone must
give in order to receive the vaccine
all three provinces said a health card
will not be required to get the vaccine
though it's asked for at almost every
stage
from making an appointment to showing up
at the clinic all provinces also said
they require a full name
address and date of birth in ontario if
you don't have a health card
you must bring another form of
government issued photo id
something undocumented people likely
don't have
that level of identification would keep
them away migrants and undocumented
people
are reluctant to access health care due
to a fear that their information will be
turned over to border services
and that they will be detained and
deported both ontario and quebec
said that any information that is
collected for vaccination purposes
will not be shared with federal agencies
in accordance with provincial health
privacy laws
but paul says this fear is deeply
ingrained in these communities
and the government isn't doing any
messaging to combat it
we keep telling them that the hospital
health care system will not report them
their information is protected
then you meet the gentleman he will tell
you that he literally had to be
coaxed into going so he didn't go blind
we're calling him marcos because he
fears he may be deported if his identity
is revealed
his work as a cleaner is considered
essential he's been disinfecting and
cleaning buildings throughout the
pandemic
last year marcos came to paul's clinic
unable to see out of one eye
he was turned away by an ophthalmologist
because he was uninsured
paul recommended he go to emergency
suspecting that there was bleeding
inside of his eye
due to complications from his diabetes
when dr crawford said to you
you're going to have to go to the
hospital you're going to have to get
this procedure done
what did you say i say i don't
want to go marco says he's heard stories
of people going in for care
and having immigration authorities
called on them too many studies we
finally convinced him to go
and we gave him a letter i called the
hospital
emerged and said he's coming in he got
admitted but then he says the hospital
told him he would have to pay
paul stepped in again i guess you'd call
it advocacy or support
led to him getting the laser surgery i
just talked to him recently
i said how's your vision he said it's
getting much better he would have been
blind
when i asked marcos how he plans to get
the vaccine
he said he's waiting for paul's call
this cleaning for me
designed my life too is toronto public
health approved
and it's specifically for appropriate
vaccine storage
paul's on a mission to get vaccines to
his patients
he's trying to set up his own pop-up
vaccine clinic
there will be phone calls to thousands
of people
to say come in and give them a heads up
and the safety of the vaccine the
vaccine hesitancy but
we're not going to collect your
information and they've come to trust
this place
it's important work but paul's clinic is
small and
resources are limited he says he's
frustrated by the lack of action from
government
after all these years they've still
continued to let these people
fend for themselves and be lost it's a
form
of apartheid healthcare because it's a
racialized
highly racialized population every
morning i wake up being grateful i'm in
canada
but often every night i go to bed
thinking about
where we've let human beings
in far less fortunate circumstances than
ours down
the federal government says it knows
that people are struggling due to job
losses and service delays
but claims it has put policies in place
like extending windows of time for
people to reapply for status
and work while permits are being
processed but all of this hinges on
finding a new job
and an employer who is willing to do the
necessary paperwork
while still waiting for health coverage
advocates say
there is a simple solution to all of the
challenges that migrants and
undocumented people are facing because
of the pandemic
grant them permanent residency that
would provide them with health care
coverage
access to emergency benefits and
eliminate the fear of being detained and
deported
one new program that has been created
allows people without status
who worked in health care during the
pandemic to apply for permanent
residency
but the requirements for eligibility are
very narrow
immigration minister marco menoccino has
said he wants to expand it
there are workers who are
doing frontline dangerous work during
the pandemic
throughout the economy all of them are
essential
all of them should have status lily came
to canada on a temporary work permit
and has been working diligently ever
since navigating the owner's government
system and various programs
in order to get permanent status and
reunite with her kids
and grandkids that was the goal back in
2014 but now
it's 2021 and i'm undocumented i have
no rights no status even she doesn't
qualify for the government's new program
despite being considered a hero hero
i don't know i just go to work i just go
to my job
and i i'm just hoping that you know the
federal government will see that
we all need the vaccine we all need
status we all need permanent residents
we are here already
we work we pay taxes so why don't you
just try and
meet us halfway